I think a lot of DNA that's coming up
anything when i first got the space the
tech space in two thousand five six
seven when i started flirting this web
two point okay and went out that Evan
cabin grows and all its people one of
the things got those two decks but like
a 90 first of all in the South I'd no
joke I said there's a holy [ __ ] every
single person here is a straight hippie
there's a for business people like fun
they figured out what I did we talk
about that in a burning torch it was
zero like conversation of like building
businesses it was unbelievable and now
it's a level what what those purists
were product people at heart I respect
where people come from you know it's a
different skill set it's a different
North Star they want to know the product
a change in the world behind the Jets
like I get it and I respect it the
problem is then you just fall into art
and that's okay too you just have to
make it city of what you're actually
doing there's nothing wrong with being
an artist and going that route it just
right now there's a belief that you can
have vote and that's something that you
can but you show better have a partner
in primates thinking about the other
part but there's too many businesses
that are too great product people and
they don't want the business person
because of all my best friend about
people on Deb's and they hate me if
you're sick you know like we have this
one's relationship they don't know their
romantic about sales people are bad
right this is bad the problem is it's
just part of the equation you don't have
you know laughing sales people with less
people back to my attorney I believed in
kenny lofton I believed in franchise
like I believe in the stuff that I
talking right now I believe it and when
we believe that much you love that I
think the best one to five
salespeople are the most noble because
not only do they believe they spent time
advocating its purpose the promise was
ninety-five percent a lot of sales
people purchase go for bonus or the
quick buck which is why the great sport